when you're ready let's try that on and
I'll introduce the world
the newest official member of the
Avengers spider-man
yeah give that away
[Music]
Spidy gave us quite the scare over this
past summer on whether or not he was
going to be pulled from the end see you
go back to the spider verse or whether
or not he was going to remain in the MCU
but fortunately Sony and Disney went on
to work out a deal and spider-man is
remaining in the MCU and during a recent
interview with The Hollywood Reporter
Disney executives and Sony executives
finally opened up about what happened
with the agreement for spider-man to
remain in the MCU and as it turns out
spider-man is back in the MCU because of
the fans how's it going everybody it's
Warren and originally we thought that it
was Tom Holland spider-man himself that
saved spider-man from leaving the MCU
and kept him there however as it turns
out we were wrong we finally figured out
what happened between Sony and Marvel
during their renegotiations for
spider-man to remain in the MCU Disney
executives and Sony executives have
opened up about the agreement that was
reached during the interview with The
Hollywood Reporter alan horne the CEO of
Disney and Tom Rothman the chairman of
Sony Pictures were asked in this
interview Allen and Tom you recently had
a little dispute over spider-man what
was the one thing above all else that
resolved that standoff over Marvel
producing the next Sony installment and
alan horne the CEO of disney responded
by saying the fan base which is
important to all of us seem to really
respond to what tom and his folks have
done before with our people they like
the fact that the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and Kevin Feige were involved
in the two spider-man films we heard
feedback out there that suggested that
joining forces once again was probably
really a good idea so as it turns out
Sony and Disney really did have our best
interests the fans best interests in
mind when they came to this deal
reaching the conclusion that spider-man
will in fact remain in the MCU but now
the question is for how long the deal
went back and forth for a very long time
until ultimately it was decided that
spider-man would remain in the MCU to
finish off his trilogy and one more
crossover film in the MCU but what
happens when Tom Holland and spider-man
are done with these two movies this
question was asked during the interview
they were asked
will this partnership continued after
the trilogy Tom you've shown you can do
spider-man without Marvel on the
animated film spider-man into the spider
verse in which Tom Rothman of Sony
replied yes we have but I agree with my
distinguished colleague this was a
classic win win win a win for Sony a win
for Disney a win for the fans the only
thing I would say is that new cycles and
the rhythm of negotiations do not
necessarily overlap and this is in the
words of Shakespeare a consummation
devoutly to be wish'd we would have
gotten there and the news got ahead of
some things and then immediately after
Tom Rothman said that Alan Horn of
Disney said I agree with that so
according to the CEO of Disney and the
chairman of Sony Pictures it seems like
spider-man was always going to remain in
the MCU the two studios would have
worked out a deal eventually but the
media didn't always report what was
going on at that exact time and this
sounds like a decision that will most
likely be reached in the future as well
both Studios realized that it is a
really good idea for spider-man to be in
the MCU so after his deal is done with
the trilogy and the crossover film they
will most likely renegotiate a deal
again for spider-man to remain in the
MCU especially because they came to this
conclusion because they realized that
the fans want spider-man in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and that's never
going to change there were also reports
that Tom Hollands spider-man himself
called up alan horne the CEO of Disney
once the deal was set to be done and
told him to get back in front of Sony he
then apparently called up Tom Rothman
the chairman of Sony Pictures and told
him that he needs to rimi twist is knee
he then according to reports pleaded
with both parties to have spider-man
remain in the MCU and for the two
companies to come to an agreement and
while this definitely could have
happened both Sony and Disney said that
Spidey is remaining in the MCU because
of the fans I'm still doing my xbox one
and ps4 giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be subscribed to my channel
like this video and leave a comment
below with your favorite superhero or
villain and your thoughts on the video
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof